a brand new supreme court showdown
brewing on capitol hill confirmation
hearings kicking off today for judge
contanji brown jackson republicans
promising to ask tough questions but say
they won't turn a hearing into a smear
campaign like democrats have
this will not be a political circus
this will not be the kind of character
smear
that sadly our democratic colleagues
have gotten very good at the most recent
supreme court nominee was subjected to
repeated accusations that were nothing
more than unfiltered religious bigotry
against her
the nominee before her was accused of
serial rape no republican senator
is going to unleash on you and attack
about your character when the hearing is
virtually over
none of us i hope have been sitting on
information
about you as a person
for weeks or months
but some of the mainstream media are
already giving the nominee cover before
hearing even starts
what josh hawley is doing let's let's be
very clear what josh hawley is doing
when he tries to do this um is he's
trying to get her killed
is trying to get violence done against a
supreme court nominee
all right greg uh
you know you know that guy don't you
yeah he's been on my show i think he
discovered he discovered the more
extreme you become the more the more you
end up on our show well you know death
threats aside i guess because
criticizing someone is is equivalent to
that the republicans get an l either way
here right because they either fight the
fight democrats at fault which takes all
their ability to stay mad about the
kavanaugh hearing away and all the moral
high ground away that they that they
believe they have but if they just do a
regular hearing this is just a
progressive on the supreme court that's
right and i would say that
i would go with that direction i would
just say keep your powder dry because
you just you're pre you're replacing an
l with an l
right this is a push and true she's
probably gonna be the most progressive
person but the fact is they lost a
liberal they're going to get a liberal
so it's kind of 0-0 so you don't want to
lose your mind over something like this
however you will be reminded in this
hearing how different republicans are
they aren't as vicious and as disgusting
in these settings i mean
when a democrat runs this it becomes a
witch trial and and in this case i would
like to see the republicans just a
little bit
tougher they don't have to go they don't
have to obsess they if they obsess over
a critical race thinking you know what's
going to happen critical race training
their what's your theory they're going
to whatever jessica
i say whatever to crt too
but anyway uh that the uh what's gonna
happen is the media is gonna galvanize
that weapon that they have which is the
demonization through
racial accusations so if you bring up
crt they're gonna call you a racist uh
speaking of disgusting i have to
apologize for my hygiene uh there was no
hot water the smoke i can't tell i
haven't no i'm apologizing to you
because i've been shaved and i stink
because i haven't bathed in two days
you're proud of that no i'm disgusted
well to clean things up a little bit
damn
so i saw a marsha blackburn video
because i didn't see all the covers
today because we're covering a lot of
things and once there's a war going on
and she really went in on her pretty
pretty quick and pretty hard about
things like parental rights that was one
thing she brought up the the idea of um
how schools are treated and where the
parents rights are but when you look at
this nominee's background one of the
things that stood out to me i guess is
an iraq and afghanistan war veteran is
that she volunteered to go defend
guantanamo bay uh prisoners of war now
her brother i will point out her
brothers in iraq war veterans so it's
not she's
immune to that but i mean how do you
think americans should see that well i
think that they should i think americans
know that our system is just different
than other places and defendants get to
have a public defender and they get to
have representation in court and um the
gitmo detainees
were given that and i mean some people
might say they shouldn't have been but
that is our system that's our system of
justice and that she was participating
in the system of justice and i don't
know if she went down there and she's
talking to her her gitmo detainee and
she's like oh hey did you know anything
about that such and such i don't think
that they were there as apologists for
them necessarily but trying to get the
those cases adjudicated
but we'll see what comes out in the
hearing i'd love to hear her explanation
i mean i'm trying to defend it right now
for her i don't necessarily have to i
would also like to say on the decorum
front i mean we saw in the kavanaugh
hearings and i think in some ways the
amy
coney barrett hearings
there was a race to the bottom and the
democrats absolutely won it i mean they
got the gold and so there's no need for
the republicans to do that because um
they've all met with her apparently they
say that she's uh quite charming uh that
she's very wise but this question about
one two two questions one she says she
doesn't actually have a judicial
philosophy
then what is your what is your
constitutional philosophy i mean that is
actually what you're there to do is to
interpret the constitution so there will
be that hit on that and the second oh
marsha blackburn she's
you're on top of it today with her um
and the other thing i would say is there
is this question that you'll hear
republicans bring up again and again
we'll see if they can figure out a way
to land any of this which is this
question of the dark money groups that
they say
money like dark money that basically
ensured that the progressives got
katanji brown jackson rather than
michelle childs as the nominee well she
was she was on obama's short list before
as well judge soft on crime is probably
going to be the theme of the of the
hearings
yeah and and you know let me just say
this she she's got the votes look she
she was she was approved to go to the
circuit court of appeals uh i think a
year ago a little over a year ago two
years ago and so and three republicans
voted for her right now she only needs
all the democrats to vote first so this
is an easy win for her the question is
and and dana made reference to this a
judicial philosophy that is not telling
people how you would vote it is your
interpretation of the constitution is it
a living document and and the democrats
for years have gone after conservatives
and they've said that if you have a
conservative judicial philosophy
then you're not qualified to be on the
court and so the democrats have created
a precedent to go after this judge your
potential justice but i think more
important is her record on crime and
specifically child porn that's something
i did a lot of as a prosecutor right now
she has to explain why her sentences
were lower than the sentencing
guidelines and here's the statute it is
his federal statute that says you've got
to give a mandatory minimum of five
years or a maximum of 20 years she very
often went under the required uh
sentencing guidelines and they say the
reason she did that was because she was
she was looking at possession as opposed
to receiving as far as i'm concerned
there's no difference between the
possession of child porn or the
receiving of child porn
if you distribute it if you make it
you're a dirt bag for sure but explain
to me justice potential justice why you
went below sentencing guidelines for the
dirt bags in our society i bet jessica's
got an explanation i don't think she
defend child porn jessica
tell us why she should be at supreme
court justice
well that's a larger question than just
this child porn uh
sentencing guidelines and josh hawley
has kind of been beating that drum he
did again today and there was in the
national review i saw you just had it
out a piece of conservative outlet
saying that these attacks are
disingenuous on her and she
said she had to explain why she went
below the guidelines absolutely they're
not i was ingenuous until she makes
disingenuous was actually in the title
of the piece she was taking notes on all
of holly's points as he was talking to
her about what cases specifically he
wants to know about and she has
according to everybody on both sides of
the aisle been extremely receptive to
both adoring type questions and hard
questions from republicans we heard
marsha blackburn bring up crt that will
definitely feature in the hearings as we
go forward
a couple things that i thought were
really important about her perspective
and it was highlighted i believe by dick
durbin talking about that she discusses
her jobs in terms of talking about how
the people who are affected by her
decisions take it and her experience as
a public defender and she would be the
first on the court to have that
experience
really frames her perspective in a
completely different way than other
people we've had on the court and
there's a very handy chart that the
washington post created about all of the
qualities that supreme court justices
have you know where they went to school
debate champions etcetera and she's the
only one that ticks every single box on
that chart listen and that makes her
pretty special it's six to three she'll
get in that's i mean it's six or three
if you're or we could just say that yes
that's a good point why don't we just
skip this and get to that hygiene
we always know what the vote's gonna be
we talked about this
every every one of these hearings all
right we gotta go
ahead hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else